sie haben die bilder die wir gerade
gezeigt haben auch gesehen wie erklären
sie den scheinbaren widerspruch zwischen
ihrer aussage und diesen bildern
ich sehe keinen widerspruch ich das so
sagen darf ich habe die kette und das
weiß man auch immer an ich bin auch
bekannt dafür dass ich mit dieser kennt
im fernsehen auftreten wie auch zuvor
eine fernsehsendung der ich da saß
aufgetreten bin ich möchte nochmal aber
an nacken ich bin ich bin froh dass bei
der ermittlung das gesamte videomaterial
ausgewertet wird und ich möchte ganz
ehrlich auch darum bitten dass man
zeigen soll wann dieser moment gewesen
sein soll weil ich mir angeblich nach
dem vorfall die kette über den kopf
gezogen haben soll und damit eine video
zu machen das habe ich nicht gemacht ich
habe die kette immer an
es ging eher darum nicht darum dass ihr
sie danach angezogen haben sondern dass
sie offensichtlich an dem zeitpunkt als
sie an der rezeption standen nicht so
sehen war diese kette und genau darum
ging es aber doch angeblich es geht auch
um den darf ich denn genau um die kette
die ich immer tragen wie forschung
gesagt und ich habe wenn sie sind auch
gestern auf der in der bams war zu sehen
ein bild von dieser videoüberwachung ich
an der rezeption stehe und nach hinten
zeigen müssen auch der moment als ich
gesagt habe ich wurde gerade beleidigt
aufgrund eines sterns auf grund sie
stellen sie nicht immer trage und ich
sage es nochmal ich bin dafür bekannt
ich bin wenn man das sieht im internet
auf so ziemlich jeden foto auf meiner
timeline auf install facebook oder im
fernsehen mit einem davidstern zu sehen
das ist für mich eine identifikation
meiner familie mit meiner religion und
ich habe stern immer an man kann es
lernen auch durch das t shirt sehen ich
meine nochmal ich wurde als jude
angegriffen das ist das was ich sage
weil ich eine stern trage ich sage nicht
dass ich irgendwie und das wird mir
nachgesagt gelogen hätte das habe ich
nicht ich trage den stern immer und ich
habe an der rezeption dem man es nochmal
wiederholt und der mann an der rezeption
hat es wiederholt gesagt packen sie in
sternberg dann können sie einchecken
also herr offering sie bleiben bei der
aussage sie hatten im hotel die ganze
zeit auch vor der rezeption den stern an
und der hotelmitarbeiter hat diesen
stern auch gesehen sagen sie
er muss ihn gesehen haben aber ich habe
noch mal gesagt ich wurde hinten
vielleicht von einem gast in der
schlange das habe ich auch so ausgesagt
bei der polizei ich möchte noch nicht
zugesagt - gerade in berichte gezeigt
worden es hätte ich bei der polizei
ausgesagt ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
ich den stern getragen hätte das habe
ich so definitiv nicht gesagt ich habe
gesagt ich hatte den stern an ich konnte
nicht sagen habe ich den t shirts ob ich
diesen stern in seiner jacke gehabt vor
der jacke hintern t-shirt vom t shirt
und es geht aber darum dass ich nicht
gelogen habe und jetzt in den film
gerade eben weil es leider so ich hatte
erst gesagt ich war nicht sicher ob ich
die stelle überhaupt an hatte das stimmt
wirklich nicht tragen sie diesen stern
auch heute
können sie einsehen und gerade nicht
alles klar
trotzdem noch einmal die frage wir
müssen sie stellen wir haben diese
bilder gesehen sie haben sie selber auch
gesehen und man sieht dass man diesen
stern nicht sieht nun haben sie ja
gesagt genau das war der grund aber
packt den stern 1 war der grund warum
sie angefeindet wurde wie ist das zu
erklären
ich kann es mir nur so erklären dass die
person die das zuerst gesagt im hotel
lobby mich ans hand muss und nicht
erkannt hat und ich habe nochmal das
habe ich in den letzten tagen auch immer
wieder betont ich setze mich seit jahren
dafür ein gegen antisemitismus ich trage
öffentlichem einen davidstern man kennt
mich eigentlich nur mit davidstern jeden
fernsehformat oder auf der bühne
auftreten
ob das sind sterne im t shirt oder auch
den t shirt ist nicht immer will habe
ich von meinem vater zu mir zwar
bekommen ich habe mehrere sterne aber
diesen stern trage ich eigentlich
gemacht das heißt ich bin auch bekannt
dafür dass sich als offen leben der
juden in deutschland als säkularer jude
das heißt ich bin nicht streng religiös
oder fromm oder orthodox aber ich bin
stolz und meine identität und ich trage
dich gern und das ist etwas wofür ich
angefeindet worden bin
herr offering in ihrem instagram video
haben sie gesagt dass der
hotelmitarbeiter ihnen gesagt habe
packen sie ihren sternbeck wenn sie
jetzt zurück denken hätten sie das video
genauso mit der gleichen formulierung
mit dem gleichen vorwurf noch einmal
aufgenommen
absolut weil es passiert es
entschuldigen sie bitte ich habe
natürlich die letzten tage waren nicht
schön und ich bin nach wie vor betroffen
denn ich wurde antisemitisch beleidigt
zwei mal an diesem abend einmal in der
schlange und an der rezeption wurde das
noch mal wiederholt und ich habe ehrlich
gesagt nicht bedenken das ist falsch
oder richtig ist nein es musste sein aus
dem einfachen grund ist passiert jeden
tag und das ist in meinem fall ist
hinterfragt wird kann ich absolut
nachvollziehen und verstehen ich kann
auch verstehen dass es nach diesem video
beweis oder nach den bildern so aussehen
würde das hätte ich nicht an gehabt was
nicht stimmt ich habe immer an gehabt
ich habe ihn in der produktion noch eine
stunde zuvor an gehabt und ich ziehe ihn
nicht aus
dem offering wie sehr fürchten sie dass
durch diese debatte oben haben sie
belogen oder haben sie die wahrheit
gesagt der kampf gegen antisemitismus in
deutschland den sie ja dadurch
unterstützen wollten letztendlich doch
geschadet hat jetzt
ich kann noch immer schwer hoffen dass
bin ich geschadet hat ich habe im
vergleich zu vielen anderen jüdinnen und
juden im mund aufgemacht und habe etwas
gesagt mich gewehrt ich habe in meinem
fall ich habe eher sorge dass man
aufgrund der berichterstattung jetzt
sich sagt wo es wäre noch schlimmer wenn
ich was sage und das darf nicht der fall
sein mir ist das widerfahren sind sie
auch derzeitig aufzustellen ich wissen
wie ich noch mal ich bin mir um die
brisanz des themas bin ich ein sehr
bewusst ich habe wir auch ein interview
zuvor gesagt ich habe die ganze nacht
wach gelegen weil noch mal das ist ein
thema mit dem ich mein leben lang
konfrontiert worden bin ich wusste was
das für wellen schlägt das ausmass und
dass ich vielleicht von vom aus täter
gemacht werde und dass ich jetzt
eigentlich gehör gelogen haben soll
darum habe ich mir keine gedanken
gemacht und ganz ehrlich das hätte ich
auch nicht gedacht aber ich werde nach
wie vor weitermachen darf ich fragen ob
unserem t shirts auf auto auf dem t
shirts das ist egal aber ich trage ihn
auch nicht weiter tragen und ich werde
noch mal weil sie mich gerade gefragt
haben ob ich es noch mal machen würde ja
ich würde wenn ich wieder antisemitisch
vielleicht werde werde ich wieder mein
mund aufmachen sagen so nicht und das
bitte ich alle anderen werden und jung
und nicht nur die denn ich habe auch von
vielen anderen seiten gehört gut eine
kette was ist mit der gruppe was ist mit
der diskriminierung
jeder sollte seinen mund aufmachen und
das ist das was ich sage ich würde es
nochmal genauso machen herr offering sie
sagen ja selbst das schlägt unglaubliche
wellen und wir versuchen hier gerade
etwas zur aufklärung des sachverhalts
beizutragen in ihrem instagram video
zeigen sie die kette vor sie ist vor dem
t shirt zu sehen auf dem video im also
auf dem überwachungsvideo ist zu sehen
dass sie wenn sie die kette tragen unter
dem t-shirt erinnern sie sich an den
moment in dem sie sie unter dem t-shirt
hervorgezogen haben
ich habe ich noch mal ich habe die kette
in die hand genommen um zu zeigen worum
es hier geht das war meine intention
zu zeigen weil ich einen davidstern
tragen und weil ich kann mich nur
wiederholen weil ich das immer mache und
die man tun und auch dafür bekannt bin
in fernsehshows auch gegen
antisemitismus sondern beziehungsweise
ich war in einer fernsehshow name ist
hart aber fair auch da geht es um dieses
thema nicht bei 18 zuschauern in der
fernsehshow irgendwie dischen museum
erst noch verlierer feidman mit dem
davidstern zu sehen und habe über
antisemitismus gesprochen ich habe
gezeigt warum es hier geht es das sind
ein jude bin stern ablegen sollen das
habe ich gesagt das werde ich genau so
wieder machen dennoch gibt es eben jetzt
durch diese diskrepanz der bilder wenn
ich da kurz ein haken darf eben jetzt
doch zweifel an ihrer glaubwürdigkeit
auch die polizei ermittelt ja nun
weiterhin wie wollen sie diese zweifel
jetzt endgültig zerstreuen
ist die verzweiflung die ich ob katze
wenn sie das video gesehen haben ich war
alleine ich war alleine an der rezeption
keiner hat irgendetwas gesagt oder
konnte mir helfen ich sage nicht das
wollte keiner helfen aber keiner war da
ich war völlig allein und das ist das
was jeden tag passiert man ist allein
was wir an diskriminierung und ich war
verzweifelt und ehrlich gesagt bin ich
immer noch weil dieser fall
wissen sie ich arbeite in dieser branche
und ich mache sowas mit sicherheit nicht
wissen auch vorgeworfen ist es
irgendwelchen pr drücken ich habe
familie
ich habe kinder ich hatte aber auch eine
großmutter die waren zu acht und nicht
alle kamen durch den zweiten weltkrieg
über diese thema macht man ehrlich
gesagt jeder irgendwelche videos oder
witze aber das ist das alltägliche mit
dem die juden juden in deutschland zu
kämpfen haben und das ist das was ich
gemacht habe und ich werde es noch mal
ich trage den ställen
velofahren vielen dank dass sie sich
diesem interview gestellt haben nach wie
vor zwei wochen auch schon bei uns bald
live vielen dank
philipp wie schätzt du die lage jetzt
ein nachdem du gehört hast auch selber
mit ihm gesprochen hast ja er war jetzt
doch sehr klar bei seiner aussage in der
bild am sonntag hatten wir ihn ja auch
schon angefragt mit ihm gesprochen und
ihm zitiert da klang das ein kleines
bisschen weicher sag ich mal hat er
gesagt es geht nicht nur um den stern es
geht doch um etwas größeres im
antisemitismus jetzt war er wieder sehr
klar in seiner aussage und hat gesagt
ich habe den stern getragen auch im
hotel und ich wurde auch wegen meines
sterns erkannt selbst und der stern
vielleicht unter dem t shirt zu sehen
war das heißt er bleibt bei seinen
vorwürfen dem ursprungs vorwürfen die
das ganze thema erst ins rollen gebracht
haben und er hätte das video ganz genau
so wieder aufgenommen
es ist es nach wie vor sehr sensibler
sehr schwerer fall man hätte ich habe
ihn ja auch gefragt ob er sich an den
moment erinnert indem er den stern recht
unter dem t-shirt hervorgezogen hat um
das video zu drehen das hat er nicht
ganz klar beantwortet wofür ich
allerdings auch etwas verständnis habe
wenn man sich nun mal nicht an jede
sekunde erinnert an so einem abend der
für ihn offenbar sehr
aufwühlend besonders schmerzhaft war
die serie topstar philipp wie sehr
glaubst du das war die frage die ich ja
auch angelow vorgestellt hatte wie sehr
glaubst du dass diese zweifel die da
entstanden sind jetzt der debatte über
antisemitismus letztendlich ein
bärendienst erwiesen haben ja ich möchte
das ehrlich gesagt nicht gilt offering
in die schuhe schieben weil diese sache
einfach noch nicht aufgeklärt ist
es wäre ich glaube den das ist
vielleicht eine lehre für das nächste
mal wenn solche vorwürfe die er auch
sehr schwerwiegend sind geäußert werden
dass man vielleicht etwas abwartet dass
man nicht ausgehend von einem vorwurf
der nur von einer seite erhoben wird
direkt darauf schließt was wirklich
passiert ist sondern
abwartet bis man mehr fakten hat videos
wie wir das überwachungsvideo heute
exklusiv gezeigt haben aber auch
ermittlungsergebnisse und
natürlich gibt es jetzt kräfte die mit
einer eigenen agenda versuchen diese
zweifel die es jetzt ja auf jeden fall
gibt zu nehmen und zu
instrumentalisieren um zu behaupten
vieles was die juden ja erzählen über
antisemitismus stimmt vielleicht gar
nicht
wohl sehr wichtig auch der hinweis von
avery
dass jetzt nichts passieren darf dass
keiner sich mehr traut zu sprechen
[Musik]